hi there my mismo I'm a sniffer dog for
French customs it's a cool job I get to
fight the bad guys who tried to smuggle
all sorts of stuff across the border and
I have colleagues across the EU doing
the same thing together we make sure
that illegal things don't get into
Europe sometimes we have to work in
rough conditions but actually we love it
people know us because we're good at
detecting illegal drugs explosives and
large amounts of cash then we have also
trained to find forbidden food or ivory
oh hang on I think I smell something
I've got to follow my nose found it oh
by the way let me introduce mutant he's
not trained yet but soon he'll be a
great partner and together will help
protect the EU borders it's a dog's life
and we love it
you